oh you work for doordash well as a as a
peddler or as a like exploiting the
people who pedal
[Applause]
we'll start with the kind of shadowy
area here what you guys like a rap about
puppeteering yeah
what are your favorite type of Puppets
the hand
one weapons which ones the hand ones
cool did you know there were more than
just one type I feel like I feel like
you didn't consider the marionette okay
hand puppets puppeteering um this this
middle front side what you want to rap
about
Wimbledon is happening right now isn't
it who's your fave
Eubanks
oh I know his name but I don't watch him
um okay his name is Chris Eubanks uh as
opposed to Chris Eubank who was a famous
British boxer he's uh he's six foot
seven and his arms are like proper
[__] long and he's like yeah he's
very good in tennis okay Wimbledon and
Chris Eubanks uh back of the room hello
suggestion did you just shout lesbians
before it even finished
wow right what uh are you yourself a
lesbian
yes uh what is what would you say is the
best thing about being a lesbian
[Laughter]
double the Wardrobe very good yeah
I mean I'm married and that's doubled my
wardrobe but
my wife just doesn't know
[Laughter]
you're looking at me going he's not
wearing women's clothes yeah not on the
outside
um okay lesbians sharing wardrobes front
this side of the room what do you want
to rap about you
the Eucharist
just because I'm an a religious
individual that's the the bread and wine
that you get in church that if you're
Catholic is transubstantiated if your
Protestant is not are you Catholic no no
no are you Protestant which one are you
you would you none you're a nun oh my
gosh she's a nun
Queen of the Eucharist and then this
this door Dash okay
what's your doordash order what'd you go
for
oh you work for doordash well as a as a
peddler or as a
like exploiting the people who pedal
[Applause]
so wait you just want me to give free
advertising to doordash okay doordash
the Eucharist we've got lesbian closet
expansion Chris Eubanks and Wimbledon
and um I've forgot I know that fun I've
forgotten what was it puppeteering of
course uh well we've got a lovely band
um we've got some lovely suggestions I
would love it if you would produce some
musical accompaniment they're gonna make
up a beat I'm gonna make up a wrap it'll
be you're nodding your head already
you're just like yeah and you're wearing
a pearl necklace that's beautiful oh my
gosh this wrap is for all of you but
mainly for you
um and uh no I hope you enjoy it
[Music]
my yellow shirted fellow when the show
maybe be the best of friends we could be
the two guys opposite to lesbians I
guess that it depends you know they're
on it in their home apartment they'd be
double in the closet not the space but
different clothes you can wear lesbians
love that [__] yeah they can share I
don't mean in a sexual way Collective
Fabrics the cotton eye on rayon yeah you
know they have this they say that looks
exceptional on you oh my gosh so
flattering just you two we can walk out
and pick some clothes as long as your
size match and the ones that you chose
flatter your complexion flatter your
skin you thought it gets dirty but not
when I begin we're moving over here yeah
hands inside but not with fingering no
it's a different kind I'm gonna hit this
I'm getting my puppet like Jim Henson
displaying The Muppets is right there on
his hand confusing the kiss they're like
it's alive no it's just my limb inserted
in some fabric best you can get you
chose the hand pop is not finger
marrying it yeah never forget we're
having fun with this Savvy hankering for
some lovely Eucharist ah what flavor is
just plain bread I do a simple wine
going straight to my head it's strange
that you get it at your first communion
red wine you're underage I'm assuming
the priests just do it to get the kids
tipsy and then they get them backstage
and they flick teams no apologies is too
rude big stack of bread yeah Jesus food
Catholics believe it transforms inside
but that's a different kind I'm glad
that you were not snide I said
Protestant or Catholic Church of England
you were like no I'm a big nun I wear
black and white that's a habit I walk
into the monastery like let him have it
all of the months I see them I choose
violence I don't like them I wish they
took of our silence and they do I know
that you sang I praise the Lord like I'm
winning and I'm Eubanks look at this I
do the forehand backhand a flick of the
wrist first name of Eubanks yes it's
Chris like me but he's got about five
inches more of me he's there serving it
down upon the court from above get the
love to the 40 I hope he wins Wimbledon
I know it's quite naughty for me to
report these and say but I'm asking guy
making people cycle in rain outside
when you're in the mood
[__] yeah bringing the food I know they
get the tips but people often are stingy
he cycled to a church saying maybe I can
bring these he crashes on the way I know
the driver knew the risk and he was
trying to bring a little river in the
Eucharist foreign
[Applause]